all right so what I'm doing right now is
I'm spacing all of the feet 16 inches
apart and I'm pre drilling holes in it
so I don't have to switch the bit every
time then I'm going to take the wood
screws and go all the way down and
baseboard will be complete once we have
these going up all the way down the wall
we should be able to fit about 65 guns
going down which should be enough what's
up we're going back to the
tried-and-true method of doing a 3d scan
with the Kinect it's always handy to
have a 3d model of somebody for a video
shoot 3d scanning people is actually
incredibly easy we just need a good
program and they need to connect you're
using an application called skin neck
plug it in make sure it's all working
aim it at your subject hit record and
basically you can scan it around move it
around or in our case just have the
subject spin in place and also keep your
hands out things that exercise and set
it out like this yeah more than enough
room for the guns based on the amount
that I fit in these three slots right
here uh I think we're pretty darn good
when it comes to gun enclosures all
righty
just waiting for stuff to dry right now
but uh yeah we've got this busted out
Wren went straight for the wettest fish
okay guys I just look look at this
pretty dark in here isn't it well check
out this that's a lot of gun dude well
I'm not even done unloading them either
like level zero this is like totally
chill use detected an intruder and then
threat level red is like oh my god yeah
this is the creepy cell phone okay what
I'm gonna try and fire this big gun
ready you are recording and it's going
okay got it everything is generally
better on the top the legs are a little
jacked up mmm this looks pretty good any
excess stuff you're not trying to scan
you just open up like 3ds max and just
delete it
all right not bad not bad for ten
minutes work